أريد أيضًا تشغيل هذا الفيديو، أعلم
أنك قد شاهدته للمشاهدين، لقد
حصلنا عليه للتو، وهم أفراد من القوات الخاصة الإسرائيلية
يرتدون ملابس مدنية
وأطباء في هذا المستشفى في
الضفة الغربية، ما الذي يحدث هنا وما
أهمية ذلك
أعني أن هذا مجرد فيديو رائع
قد تظن أن هذا كان مشهدًا
من برنامج Netflix الذي يعرض FAA، حيث ترى
القوات الخاصة الإسرائيلية تدخل
مستشفى في مدينة جانين بالضفة الغربية المحتلة
ليس من الكوماندوز أه أو
حوالي عشرة كوماندوز أنا  يجب أن يقولوا إنهم
متنكرون في زي مدنيين بالإضافة إلى
طاقم طبي، بعضهم نساء
يرتدين الحجاب وقتلوا ثلاثة
نشطاء فلسطينيين. تتفق كل من حماس وإسرائيل على
أن الأفراد الذين
قُتلوا في هذه الحالة كانوا بالفعل
مسلحين فلسطينيين
يقول الجيش الإسرائيلي إنهم على صلة بهم.
حماس وكذلك الجهاد الإسلامي الفلسطيني
أه ويقولون إنهم
متورطون في هجمات على القوات الإسرائيلية
وكذلك يقتبسون الترويج
لنشاط إرهابي كبير
يقول الجيش الإسرائيلي إنهم كانوا
يختبئون في ذلك المستشفى عندما
قتلوا المستشفى من جانبه يقول
أن واحدًا على الأقل من الرجال كان
يتلقى العلاج من إصاباته
وكان مستشفى للعمليات، وكان
جيريمي فيه مرضى لأن هذا
يحدث، نعم أعني انظر إلى أن
هناك حماية دولية
للمستشفيات، تفقد تلك المستشفيات تلك
الحماية بمجرد المقاتلين  يستخدمون هذه
الأسباب لأغراضهم القتالية،
لا بد أن يكون هناك نوع من الاستخدام النشط أه
لهذا المجمع غير الواضح هنا ولكن من
المؤكد أن هؤلاء كانوا مسلحين يختبئون في
مستشفى قتلته القوات الإسرائيلية